if you are reading timcast news you are
getting our best attempt at just telling
you what's happening we are not trying
to trick you or manipulate you or help
anybody win an election
that's how you get it done
the problem is these people at these
companies like Gizmodo Jezebel whatever
they're they're lying for clicks why
well their bosses tell them to not so
much overtly they say hey you're not
pulling your weight your articles aren't
doing very well so what does the writer
do chases the algorithm to try and
figure out what gets the most clicks
timcast news does not exist to generate
Revenue it exists because we want there
to be some good uh effective journalism
out there be it illad on the ground in
New York capturing that viral video that
took over the internet for the past week
though we're coming for your children
thing or an article by Chris Bertman
explaining
just what the feud was to the point
where Ryan Cranston is like wow thank
you for being honest about what happened
it's not like it's a positive story
about them it's just we're not lying
about him yeah we're not going to make
money off that